hi guys how are you
great thank you and hi drew how did you
end up being cast in this movie what was
that process
like for you it was really serendipitous
i mean
i i i um knew jenny rim who's one of the
producers on this movie
from a previous project and they were
storyboarding over the moon at that
point
and they needed someone to come and do
some demos uh
so they could finish their storyboard
and so they brought me in to do the
scratch record
and we recorded the whole movie in one
day um
and and i don't know something happened
when
at the end of the day we recorded rocket
to the moon
um and i just really connected with
fei-fei
and um they loved it and
i still can't believe it sometimes like
they love that take i just went in there
and the first take
that i sang was actually the one they
put into the movie
so it was crazy just crazy everything
about this is
a little insane this process was so
special because i
really got to be there from the very
beginning of the inception and see the
layering that happens
in an animation process um
you know to feel really like this this
huge effort is made by so many people
all of the animators and
animators and actors and engineers that
they're all trying to create this world
and create these characters
um so of course like you know that was
really exciting but
personally for me i've never gotten to
play a specifically written
chinese character i was incredibly
um excited and proud to be a part of
this
proud to be a part of this all asian
cast um
i think you know it's it's really uh
doing such a wonderful thing at telling
um a truly authentic and
um daring story about a young girl who's
trying to build a rocket ship to the
moon to prove the existence of this
goddess
to me it's a continuation of of what
crazy rich asians
john chu said he said it's not a is not
a movie it's a movement and i feel like
that
that philosophy has extended into the
world of animation now with over the
moon i mean when you have
movies like crazy rich asians and and
tiger tail
and you know and the farewell and and
now
they're they're you know to me we're
breaking ground with um
with over the moon this is such a very
very big movie
and um just so unique in its scope and
breadth and
um you know with this very ancient story
but in a very modern take and you know
what a great cast
and what a beautiful beautiful
production it's just
it's very very big and i'm so proud to
be a part of it
i just knew that the content of the
script was going to be so moving to
people and i just
i saw the illustrations beforehand and
they were extraordinary
but the process of actually recording it
was so fun
glenn keane is just like the most loving
supportive man
um he's so fun to work with he really
plays with you
um he wants you to go all the way
you know be as free and as playful as
possible and then he reigns you in a bit
and gives you specificities and it's
just like such a fun
um a fun way to work as an actor i've
heard that glenn always has
a sketch pad with him that he's always
drawing
um how did you guys kind of see your
characters come to life over
however many recording sessions you had
and then finally seeing
the final product something that really
stuck out to me is that every
time that glenn drew her she looked
really powerful and grounded
even though she was only 12 years old
you know and so
from that i could already tell like they
face headstrong and
confident and driven and so his his
art really inspired me inspired the
character
you're working with the legend and um he
has a very unique style like in
animation where
when you're when you're doing when
you're in a voiceover booth you know
he was there with me like in in the room
and so you have that kind of intimacy of
directing him
and and it it allows you really to to
zero in on story you're not just kind of
like it's not like doing a voice-over ad
and doing it over and over again
you're you're doing something you know
everything you're saying any
anything comedic is going to is going to
serve us the story
he's just so um supportive and
so knowledgeable and just so aware of
exactly what you need
in there it's such a specific thing of
what an actor needs
inside of a booth when you're kind of
just like working
where you just don't know what it's
going to look like you don't know what
it's going to sound like and what it's
going to be like and none of the actors
are there
and it's just very strange but he knows
and
it's it's really amazing he's incredible
it was so exciting to meet him i mean
he's made some of my favorite
animations of all time um i think i
blacked out i i don't even remember what
i said
but um it was probably like hi
thanks for making this thanks for
including me i'm so honored i don't know
i really got to play and and bring all
of myself to it and
you know they were filming us during the
the recording process so
even in the film like there's like
certain looks i'm like
that's kind of a thing that i think i do
and i'm sure they took many
crazy things that i was doing in the
booth that day um
as inspiration for animating and i loved
that i thought that was so cool
he's just a master at storytelling uh
and i'm so
thankful for you know the characters
that he's
made an animation a large part of that
like inspired me
to to pursue art you know so
he's been he's been so influential to so
many people and i'm glad
that he could direct me because he
should be storytelling for the rest of
his life i i there's something about his
style that um
fosters just the sense of play it was
always
fun working with him in the studio and
he's also such a clear
um he has such clear visions of the
world around
you so for an actor he gave me
everything i needed and
i felt like i got to learn so much from
him when you saw it finished were you
completely
blown away it's just a beautiful
beautiful movie it's magnificent it's
really
it's just uh i think something that the
whole family can enjoy too
it's really special the chinese
landscape is beautiful and we're also
seeing
a lot of different chinese faces and
asian faces that all look a little
different but are all
true and then then you go to this
fantastic world
like it's insane and you see this moon
goddess dressed by guo pay and
the way she moves i mean it it
added so much for me to be able to see
what the world was it gave me a lot of
perspective
so helen park was one of the songwriters
and i had seen um a show k-pop that she
had worked on
and i was like okay so like i already
know what i gotta bring
to this because i know what helen
probably has in mind
so like you know there was there was
there was a lot of imagination
[Music]
like imaginary work that was happening
um
and of course the song itself is like
such a cool
song um but it really wasn't until like
i saw
the full animation that like my mind was
blown and i was like
i'm so cool i feel so
cool i've never felt so cool in my
life so so
i i was like oh this is so awesome and
and even better than that like
i know that none of that would have been
possible without the entire
collaboration collaboration and the
entire team it was just so beautiful
when they first showed me some of the
animation for rocket to the moon
i cried a lot um and then they had to
take a really long break
in the studio because like i was too
like snotty and everything
so i couldn't say my lines um it's a
perfect family film for this time i mean
i think that's something that is
inclusive
um diverse and has a cultural
specificity
for a global tale for something that's
universally accessible
at its core it's about life loss
and love and i think that you know you
the more specific you go culturally
the more fulfilling it is globally and
as well as artistically
so many actors talk about how the only
real way to achieve
immortality is to be a voice in an
animated movie because
little kids are going to be watching
this movie in 200 years are you
have you thought about that at all yeah
people have been bringing that up today
and i'm like oh yeah
i i i just hope that um
they feel like they connect to faith
they i hope it inspires people to
learn more about science and i hope they
want to sing the songs and
i don't know i i'm really excited for
kids to watch